but i was in hell because all i was
doing was obsessing
over her with this guy who was playing
for the steelers
to the point where the only like thing i
was focused on i looked up his combine
stats
and i was like which one of these can i
compete with like that [ __ ] matters
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen i'm danica patrick
and i'm pretty intense today on the show
is another pretty intense person his
name is aubry marcus
aubry is the founder of onit which is a
lifestyle brand
that's based on holistic health so they
have products
as well as equipment and anything to do
with your overall wellness to take care
of yourself
he's a motivational speaker he of course
has his own podcast it has a huge
following
and he just really believes in
optimizing your total health with mind
and body
he's also known for raising awareness
for psychedelics
so as you can imagine we had a really
interesting conversation
and um he also believes in open
relationships
i i mean look i i had a lot of questions
and
i'm not going to say judgments but for
the record i don't think that i would do
some of the things that he does but
that's okay because it's our differences
that make us interesting and they also
create
great conversations so uh we dove into
some of those
some of those very interesting topics
pretty well and
i came away with a definitely an amount
of respect for him
and um ultimately his goal though is to
grow
and grow he does enjoy so one of the
things that i think is
i just admire so much in people is when
they
have a passion for something and they
find a way to
make that into their job their life
their reality and so
that's on it right it is like what a
cool company
i would just i just want to hear i want
to hear about it i want to hear
first off what made you want to start
that company
that's the culmination of really what
i'd always loved the most
which was the dedication to being a
little bit better tomorrow than you were
today
right like and whatever that was that's
what i was the most passionate about is
like
how do you get better and i was a little
bit obsessed with it maybe a little too
competitive maybe
i had a lot of other reasons why i was
kind of into it but the process
of becoming better and finding the tools
to make myself better
that was always something that drove me
and so creating and having the
opportunity to create a company
that's dedicated to that purpose you
know we call it total human optimization
like
all of the ways that you can get a
little bit better at whatever you want
to
do you know and build a company around
that
i mean it's it's such a dream to be able
to have something that i'm that
passionate about
and then have a business that can do
that for so many other people
provide all the tools the mindsets the
the different ways that people can
access that state of
and the confidence yeah to get a little
bit better give an overview of the
company and then i'd like to kind of
dive in a little bit further into more
details but i think it's
be beneficial for people to understand
the scope of it first
yeah i mean it started with
supplementation and this started for me
when i was really young so my stepmom
worked with all of pat riley's teams and
so that was the lakers in the 80s that
was the knicks in the 90s that was the
heat in the 2000s
and so i was a basketball player myself
so she had a lot of nutritional
supplements that she would work with
these athletes
so every game day i had a stack of
supplements on a paper towel
and they worked they were good like they
made a difference
what did you feel i knew that when i was
performing out there i had a little bit
more stamina i had a little bit more
clarity i just felt more supported
in my body like my mental focus my
physical
endurance these different things were
slightly modulated
to the like they're they were improved
that you noticed
i noticed it was it was noticeable you
know
and she wouldn't give those to me it was
just a game that was the game day stack
and then there was a test day
there was a test day stack and these
were different colored stuff i didn't
care enough to really
go in and figure out what they were she
was just my stepmom she provided this
but i knew that the i knew that they
were different there was a different
number of them they were different color
and on test days i felt my brain firing
a little bit better so i had this
understanding in my head that these you
know
natural compounds because she only dealt
with these natural substances
could actually improve my performance in
a way that i could feel
so i carried that with me through my
life and understood that you know
supplementation was something that i
could use in a targeted way
to improve my performance and that's
really where
on it started but that's just where it
started mm-hmm
it just started the idea right that was
the idea observing that it worked
observing that it worked and then
realizing that well all right
if i have a test day and i have a paper
towel full of like
nine different things what if i took all
nine of those different things and put
them in one pill right and that made it
way
easier yeah and that was the aha moment
that was the improvement to the market
because
i would go to my shelf and like when i
had to perform mentally
for whatever task that might be i would
have to take this pill out of this
bottle and this pill out of this bottle
and this peeled out this bottle
and sometimes i'll just be too lazy to
do it but i was like if i combine these
all in one yeah you know then that could
be something that was really
special then i could just increase the
dose or decrease the dose depending on
how strong i wanted it to be but i would
have everything i needed
in that same formula and so that's where
it started it started with those
but i knew that that's not where it was
going to end
because you can't just take supplements
you got to eat right you got to
also have the right mindset and you got
to train right in order to have the
results
that are going to get you where you want
to go so where on it started with the
supplements like alpha brain
shroom tech sport and new mood and these
different concepts where i combined a
bunch of
ingredients in one formula brain okay
alpha brain
mood okay new mood you know sport okay
shroom tech sport
like got it you know like that's where
it started but then we
started to add in all of these other
training methodologies all these other
mindset
practices all the other functional foods
and
really created this company around that
idea
so your first product was the first real
product for on it was alpha brain
we had some i was experimenting with
some hangover supplements because i was
part of this could apply to so many of
us i was partying a lot i was partying a
lot back then and so
that was probably one of the things that
i personally needed the most at that
point but realizing that if i'm trying
to sell
35 dollar you know hangover supplements
people are like
no yes are you going to do it you
wouldn't pay 35
to get rid of a hangover apparently a
lot of money apparently the world didn't
want to pay that
well that's just so excited you could
accomplish so much more of your day and
get a workout in
i agree i agree i thought it was a good
idea too but the world disagreed
but the world agreed with the idea that
improving your cognitive performance
was something that was worth having a
premium supplement
you know and so that's where alpha brain
really
formed that first kind of shift that
pivot into the company of something that
all right this isn't something to help
us who are doing bad stuff to our body
this is something to help
everybody go from good to great and
that's um that's really where we
kind of shifted the mentality and that's
kind of july of 2011 where i mark the
founding of on it
well i can't wait to try i haven't tried
any of it but no you'll like it
you guys are gonna get a super care
package it's gonna be like a giant box
like the un
comes in with a helicopter and like
drops a crate and then it's just gonna
be everywhere drone delivery
drone delivery phone delivery um
well i think that uh you also have
workout programs right so
we were kind of talking about this
before because i do crossfit and i was
like i was looking at
your your gym in austin texas where
you're based right
and um just kind of you have those
primal bells which
are awesome they have a gorilla they're
a gorilla kettlebell basically
they're super cool um but your your
your gym when we were talking about it
like i said it looks
like it it reminds me of what i do with
crossfit with kind of that open gym
and primal bell kettlebells and you know
lifting weights
similar you know for sure so but you
you you were you started to sort of
explain to me what was different
which was really interesting to me
because i love learning more and going
deeper so tell me what is the
you know what makes your gym unique well
one of the beauty let me talk about the
beautiful parts about crossfit the
beautiful
parts about crossfit is the community
that it creates yeah right because
everybody
is striving towards the same workout
they're doing the same thing
you get to put your name on the board
and everybody it's so supportive you
know i've gone through
my fair share of those work it's so
supportive everybody's encouraging each
other they're cheering for the last
place person
more than the first place by far fired
up and everybody's supporting themselves
so so we tried to keep that aspect of
things right like where
we want people to like really be
encouraging each other so we'll have
you know relays on the skierg and the
assault bikes and the different in the
different ways that we're training in
these different circuits that we're
doing and try to build that and then
you know write the names on the board
but what we're shifting from
is the kind of strict adherence to the
olympic style lifts
so focusing a lot more on the
unconventional training methodologies
like kettlebell lifting like you know
steel mace training like
the clubs and we still do some barbell
stuff for sure but we're you're not
going to see people doing as many kind
of steel mace
so steel mace is like an old from the
1200s it was an old
persian pilani wrestler training
methodology where they have a big
weighted head and we made them steel
they used to be out made out of
different material but
a big weighted head and then a pretty a
hollow handle
so that the weight is extremely offset
and what you do that is you get it in a
lot of rotational movements
and then you can use that unbalanced
weight to help your kind of proprio
reception and help
stabilize yourself so that you're
lifting and
doing explosive exercise but also
focusing on stability rather than the
symmetrical lifting that
you find in kind of barbell training but
even in our barbell training we'll do
some off-weighted stuff like i don't
know if you've ever tried to do
bench press with just one weight on one
side
have you ever tried that i can't say i
have accidentally accidentally i'm like
that sure wasn't
a 10 on that side it's so hard like you
think you're a stud
like go in there and then put a 45 on
one side of the bar
yeah and do your bench press that way
and have nothing on the other side of
the bar
like watch what your body has to do to
compensate to that off-loaded
way because in actuality that's the way
it is like someone's going to be
if you're in like a contact sport of any
sort or you're
competing or doing anything you're going
to have somebody on your right side
that's not on your left side that's
giving you resistance so you're going to
have
things that are offloaded so it's
preparing people for more functional
you know like a more functional life of
exercise
you know training and that's not
everything we do but we mix that in
in kind of a an interesting way and try
to find ways to mimic
what we would experience in the real
world which is off balance off-weighted
in in different ways
and then really take a long time to you
know warm up
cool down focus on that kind of
elasticity of the muscles as well as as
the
explosive kind of power system that can
drive you to kind of
achieve those you know strength and
power goals
yeah what do you do what's your what's
your sort of weekly routine
yeah i mean it's everybody always
wonders like to have to work out all day
every day
you know do i no definitely not i mean
it's like sometimes it can be fast
you know like we'll have um you know
we'll have like those
self-powered you know treadmills that
are on the on the car
oh yeah yeah the air runner or something
yeah exactly yeah you have a curve
and you know if you push yourself doing
sprints on the curve doing tenth of a
mile and you do
yeah you know five to seven of those
just all out
yep you're pretty good yeah and you
could do like a skierg test which is the
yeah that you're pushing down yep you
know and you can go for
a 500 meter full sprint on that like how
fast can you do that or
what like what are these things and you
can actually get pretty much your
workout
and you can add some other stuff if you
want too you can get your workout fast
that way and sometimes it's slower
sometimes i'll just grab the mace
and it'll be more like i'm just dancing
and playing for an hour
just twirling it around moving
and i really try to listen to my body
now at this point because i don't have
anything particularly i'm training for
so i just try to mix it up and an
experiment sometimes i'll do is swim
laps sometimes i'll go in there and
and then get in one of those workouts
where i'm trying to put my name on the
board or
sure competing with somebody yeah the
varieties that variety is valuable yeah
whether you're working on super high
intensity or you know one rep maxes
versus something where you're going for
volume
and you know the tw something that takes
20 or 30 minutes versus something that
takes
five um or for crying out loud 20
seconds sometimes
um it's working different different
capacities
um to tune them um you're also an
author yeah right um so you have two
books out um your last book called own
your day own your life
the first one was really like an online
course but yeah so the main book is
on the day on your life and i wanted to
put all of the knowledge that
i'd accumulated through the founding of
on it through the interaction with
you know so many champions in the sport
i mean we were talking before the
podcast the
initial founding investor in on it was
bode miller and that's actually where we
got the name
on it was conversations i used to have
with him and
you don't know he's an olympic skier won
the gold
world championships and an amazing
athlete
across the board what do you say to you
you're so on it that we would say that
about anything like that didn't matter
what we were doing like if he skied a
good race
like man i was [ __ ] on it crash but i
was on it like you know and like if i
was
if we were playing pick up basketball
i'd be like man i was on it today
if we were in the club like i was on it
or like whatever it was
that was just the epitome of us being at
our very best
super authentic so that was like well
let's just call the company that
and let's make it about that let's make
it about creating those moments we're
like now i was on it
how old is the company the july 2011
was when that was was really the start
of it um
yeah so then taking all this knowledge
that we've gained throughout the years
from
you know obviously he was a skiing
champion to the mma champions to the
football to the you know basketball
baseball
all the other extreme sports all the
different doctors and all the
the different you know exercise
physiologists and kinesiologists and all
the
nutritional experts and putting this all
together
you know really is is where
the company was founded but then the
company's this wide-ranging
you know thing of all of these different
tools but how do you make that
concise enough to really help people in
a guided in a guided way like
it was difficult to get and access all
that information even though we had this
company so i was like i want to make
write it all down right put it in a book
and what's the best way to do it well we
thought about
a lot of books have these 40-day
challenges and these 30-day things and
most people drop off after five days and
you know you really look at the
adherence
for these longer programs and it's not
that great
yeah i was like all right well what if
you just lived one day
the best you possibly could yeah you
know and then you could repeat that day
however many times you wanted to
way to think of it and so that was
really the the formation of the book
like how do you have a repeatable
best day possible and then that starts
from what you do when you wake up
you know like what's the first thing you
put in your body and we called it the
morning mineral cocktail right which is
you know a little bit of sea salt a
little bit of lemon a lot of water
you need to start your day then you
start focusing on all right your
circadian rhythm well you want to get a
little light in your system
you know because that's going to wake
the body up that's me i'm light
activated
comes up i'm there there it is right and
that's that's the way human beings are
naturally
designed so you want to get some
hydration mineralization you want to get
some light
and then movement is another way to
trigger the circadian rhythm response
and like
actually let you know that you're awake
rather than reaching for that
adrenaline button of that cup of coffee
is the first thing to wake you up
get light get light do a little movement
and then save your coffee
for when you feel that next little lull
okay okay you know and so we
i'm a coffee drinker too no doubt about
it use it for both but maybe
talking about the second cup in the
morning to being one cup
right well yeah i mean try that try the
try the salt light
movement you know because the movement's
really key too
my movement i mean i think to myself i
get up i walk downstairs i
make a cup of coffee not enough it's
really bright it's never enough coffee
ever
um and then you know the lights coming
in and i'm i
feel light activated like that's what's
helping me wake up but when you say
movement please explain like how much
are you really
talking about more than that so it's
it's at the brink of not quite a workout
yep but more than you would do in a
natural state
so for me my favorite thing is to swim i
have a
you know not a huge pool but even if i
swim just 10 laps
you know and i swim pretty hard then i
get like a good
my breath is moving and i'm i'm like
breathing heavy my heart rate goes up a
little higher it's about like getting
your
heart rate activated getting your body
moving in that way so
you could do a couple burp you know 10
burpees or whatever you could do some
air squats you could do some push-ups
you could go swimming you could go for
like
a quick little jog nothing that's going
to get you sore or tired
yeah in a in a long way but it's
something get the blood pumping
yeah and if you do that and then you
expose your body to enough light than
the photoreceptors are going to wake up
the circadian rhythm it's going to
down regulate the melatonin that's been
keeping you asleep and then wake you up
in the most natural way and then for me
then i'll go into my
you know breakfast unless i'm doing some
kind of cold therapy in the morning
which sometimes i do
i'll go into breakfast and then it's
usually after breakfast
that i get when breakfast is going to be
high fat
higher protein you know high nutrient
density lower carbohydrate because
that's just going to make me even
sleepier when those carbs
cause the insulin spike and then the
insulin comes in and you get
hypoglycemic which is the absence of
blood sugar and then you get really
tired
so try to keep it higher fat higher
protein particularly for breakfast
and then after that that's when i enjoy
my cup of coffee
i [ __ ] can't wait yeah you like
that's a cup of coffee even better
makes it so much better because i know
i've gone through all of the steps
normally that i needed to
and then i have that cup of coffee
i have a hard time i tried to eat on the
circadian like
fasting method like that's like 13 hours
off
i can't even do that yeah intermittent
fasting yeah i suck at it it's more than
three not really sure that you need it
at least 16 hours
yeah that's not for me try and convince
me why that's for me
or for anybody you know because you do
that right i do it sometimes
i actually tend to go with like a full
day fast every
when i feel like i need it so i'll go
like a 36 hour fast
um rather than a daily intermittent fast
but really this is excellent for your
metabolism like old wisdom used to be
you want to eat a bunch of small meals
throughout the day
but really that means that your
metabolic system is working constantly
and the body works better when it has
time to work hard and then
recover for longer periods so it's
giving yourself
more of a break to recover and during
those recovery cycles
that's when the body body can start some
of its natural cleansing and
detoxification protocols
like people think like detox we got to
go do this detox and
detox this thing the body's detoxing 24
7.
naturally naturally it's happening so
when you're not when it has nothing else
to do
you know the body has a certain limited
amount of energy when it has nothing
else to do it's not digesting food it's
not releasing insulin it's not
dealing with all the other things it's
doing then what is it going to be
naturally doing well it's going to be
cleaning house
it's going to be cleaning the room you
know and so that's really the principle
behind it
is it's healthier for you know that kind
of longevity and the ability to kind of
clean the body while it's not working on
something else which is
the digestion and assimilation of these
food and nutrients
do men and women have a different
reaction to this
like hunger and this because
i really hope you're going to say yes
and women need to eat more often but
that's how i feel but what is the
research shown as far as like the
hormones go for
man you're not wrong you're not wrong i
think intermittent fasting is almost
universally beneficial to men
but with women it can alter and affect
uh your kind of hormonal profile
throughout the day
so being mindful of that you know
intermittent fasting is not going to be
the same you know just biologically we
have different
hormone release schedules and the way
that the organism is
designed is slightly different and that
also applies to ketogenic diets too like
pretty much universally men can handle
a much closer adherence to a really high
fat diet
and a ketogenic diet protocol but that
may affect the hormone profile
of a woman differently and that's just
what the research and the science shows
so
you have to be mindful to take a look at
that generally it's good to experiment
with it and check it out and if
yeah and if like you haven't really
tried it like
you should for sure try it but also know
maybe it's not for you
yeah and i've i've read that too i re i
watched some you know youtube video on
what's the
perfect diet and maybe it was a ted talk
actually and
basically when they went into the
science of
using you know using people
to test the program of certain foods and
how it reacted in their body and insulin
levels and
metabolism and everything that their
someone reacted with a huge spike
to rice let's say and another person
didn't react barely at all and yeah rob
wolf talks about this a lot
you know i mean he might be what you're
referring to i think it's book wired to
eat
you know he's actually talking about
measuring your blood sugar response and
like
somebody will have a huge response to
plantains but not to white rice and so
the way that we are is different and i
think we have to really celebrate that
difference
of the organism and pay attention and be
curious and to like look
and see how we feel and like what we're
actually
what we're craving what's what you know
and why
and observe that yeah deserve it long
enough that you don't just is it an
emotional
thing or is it something right a real
true like physical
need and look at the bot like the body
isn't we look at the body as one thing
the body is a bunch of things like your
gut which is
you know where so many of the different
cells are that's a bunch
of bacteria really that's actually
making up the majority of the life form
in your body is all of these bacterias
in your gut
so if you have a healthy biome they may
be craving certain foods
that are going to be nourishing for them
if you have an unhealthy microbiome
let's say a bunch of candida
in your stomach which is yeast you may
be craving sugar all the time because
that's what the yeast wants to thrive
yeah so you might have two
different messages coming from your body
itself that really does
need it but you need to right but what
part of the body is sending that message
is this the candida that's saying yeah
feed me more sugar and alcohol
because i want to thrive and then that's
going through your neural pathways and
you're saying like
uh let's have some sugar but really
that's not the real you that's actually
a part of you
that's coming in and sending that
message so it's really kind of
understanding that we're this
amalgamation of all of these cells
that have this like kind of like loose
agreement to work together
but we want the best part of us so does
that come from
literal testing or is this more of an
awareness it can it can't come from
testing so you do
you can do like a little poop test and
check your microbiome
and uh nothing better than swabbing your
poop and sending it in the mail
you know and figuring out what's really
going on down there
what uh can you do this otherwise is
there a way to sort of just
go through like a few week process of
testing something out
is there more just sort of observation
awareness to be a little more present
i think it's good to have some data
first so like well there's a couple ways
to do it one
you can go on at least a minimum 12 day
sugar cleanse yeah right so that's going
to actually really chill out the yeast
in your stomach all of us have it to a
certain degree and it's there
for a purpose you know it actually a lot
of the candida and a lot of the
pathogenic organisms in our stomach
they actually hold on to some of the
toxins that we're getting because
there's toxins everywhere and
in our food in the air and the water
it's it's all over the place so it
they actually serve the purpose of
holding on to that for us and like
keeping it
inside their cells that's kind of their
food so we're supposed to have a little
bit of that so they can absorb some of
those heavier metals or different things
that might be coming in
but going through some kind of cleanse
so you can actually get that back in
balance
is one way to do it so you go through it
usually the science says about a 12-day
sugar cleanse will start to shift you
know your microbiome
and that's one way to do it the other
way be do some testing
realize what your issues might be and
then apply some kind of solution to that
that might be helpful as well a lot of
times that will involve a cleanse
sometimes it can involve a
pharmaceutical
like an anti-fungal or sometimes it can
involve you know some different dietary
choices
and some different ways that you're
helping your system
with probiotics and then just some of
the
anti-fungal foods and supplements that
are available
that could maybe help you but but yeah
getting some kind of data point where
you can really understand
what's going on is always really helpful
yeah well
i feel like you agree that the mind is
also a really important thing as a part
of this puzzle
puzzle like i think you've said that you
love this sort of puzzle of the brain
and it intrigues you and that's part of
what
made you want to do the program and
write the book and that there are
three major like themes of the mind
to deal with in your life and the first
one being forgiveness for past mistakes
explain that well
we have this idea that we should have
been perfect
and should have always been perfect and
should have should have should have and
really the message is stop [ __ ] on
yourself
like all of us just stop [ __ ] on
yourself if you could have done better
you
would have done better you know like at
that point you did the best you could
with what you had
and like really understanding that the
you of now
cannot go back in time to the you of
then and say like i should have done
that because i know that now well you
didn't know that then you know and you
weren't able to
do that so forgiveness is the crucial
piece of saying like look i did the best
i could then and i can do better now
you know and that's okay and i'm i can
do better tomorrow than i'm able to do
today like who i am right now
is tomorrow's idiot like i'm always
learning
yeah like we're always learning but the
problem is if you don't forgive yourself
then you're going to punish yourself
because we are the adjudicators
of our own happiness our own success
like we're the judge
and if we are punishing ourselves for
something we did in the past we're going
to deny ourself
the pleasure enjoyment success of the
present and the future
to punish ourselves for that thing that
we haven't forgiven ourselves
so we got to forgive ourselves in order
to actually
change the present and the future
otherwise we're going to live in this
punishment paradigm
where we're going to make ourselves
suffer because we feel like we deserve
to suffer
is there something that comes to mind
that you had to do that
i don't know all the time other than all
the time
all the time you know i mean i i just
transitioned a long-term relationship
that i have that was
a beautiful and challenging relationship
with um you know my girlfriend whitney
and and we just
transition that relationship and i can
look back and be like
wow what an idiot [ __ ]
like blind like how many mistakes did i
make
in this whole process like
unbelievable amount of mistakes that i
made in this whole process
and but nonetheless that was the best i
could at the time you know and i know
that both of us made these same mistakes
but really we both loved each other the
best we could
we really did and you know and like that
knowing that we loved each other the
best we could
and we made all these mistakes has
allowed us to be
like incredible friends and allies and
still teammates
to this day and in some ways you know
that acknowledgement was the crucial
part of that like yeah wow i'm so sorry
like i really did things you know
that i would never do now and i'm really
sorry about all the ways that i was
blind to these things but
you know i really did love you the best
i could and she says the same to me and
then we're able to kind of
move forward well where'd you come up
with the word transition because you use
that
specifically as opposed to broke up or
something like that
and i feel like there's probably a
reason
there is a reason because i think
there's a there's a paradigm there's a
conditioning that says
if you're having sex with somebody and
you're in a relationship
and then you're no longer in that
relationship that person is out of your
life
you know and that's the story that we're
told and so it is a breakup
you're breaking up all communication
you're breaking up all
alliance all like all support that you
had for each other
that's one way you can do it and
sometimes maybe you have to maybe if
your emotions are entangled or your
you know sexual cravings are so strong
that you just you have to give yourself
some space i get that
but in a more conscious way you can say
okay
we're going to leave a lot of these
things behind this idea that we're in
this relationship this idea that we're
working towards
some kind of romantic partnership for
the future
but we're just transitioning to a system
of support
friendship alliance and allowing
ourselves to love each other in a more
platonic way
love each other like great friends would
love each other rather than love each
other like great lovers would love each
other but it's just a transition a shift
of framework and structure but it's not
a breakup
it's not that we don't talk anymore it's
not that we aren't going to help each
other out it's not that
we're not going to go surfing on the
boat you know every once in a while
and hang and still have the same friends
you know so i think that's
really uh you know the way that i look
at it is that it doesn't have to be
an end it can just be something
different
you know an evolution do you feel like
this
sort of perspective on the relationship
is um
a result of being in an open
relationship
certainly helps good lord it's hard
enough
please tell me how you dealt with more
and why like
what why that that would make it harder
i would think
but go for it it was you're having a
great
great uh transition it was it was one of
it was the hardest thing i've ever done
i've never felt
more suffering more pain
more ego destroying
moments where i mean there's moments
where you know whitney would be with
one of her other lovers and i would be
in so much
discomfort in all aspects
of like particularly actually i would be
like i was like i remember one time in
new york i was like crawling around in
the ground she was with a particularly
aggressive lover
and that was like really hard for me you
know at that point
and like i was like crawling around on
the ground and i like i didn't know if i
wanted to throw up
or like punch a wall or like cry
or and i just i just had to start
i don't pray often but i just had to
actually start praying i was like please
help universe like please
i can't go any further why don't you
guys agree to this
well that's th that's the challenging
part but what
the the reward is of those challenges is
you start to realize you start to
understand why that is hurting why is
this hurting me sure
what is causing this pain why is her
enjoying herself and enjoying somebody
else why is that causing me pain
why is her happiness causing me pain
that does that need
to be there or is this my attachment my
competition my desire to be the special
one my desire to be
validated as the only one that she's
attracted to which makes me
greater than everybody else which boosts
my like what are the reasons behind this
and then you start to get really curious
about that when you really understand
like this shouldn't feel this bad she's
having fun or i'm having fun
and we're feeling so terrible maybe we
don't have to feel that terrible so
it ended up being the most valuable
learning process
that i've ever had and i really realized
through this process that i was
i required the validation of
a lover to make me feel like i was
worthy of love i required them
like wanting me in a sexual way in order
for me to feel like i was worthy of even
loving myself
and this unwound that pathology
through pain and introspection and and
allowed me to really understand that
which allows me to feel like
i'm whole and i don't need anything that
i used to need
because if we didn't go open we would
have just gone into serial monogamy
you know because she needed the
validation of different people loving
her i needed the validation of different
people sleeping with me
you know so we would we split up and we
would have continued to just
go a year two years you know
however long with the person until we
sucked up all the validation that we
could get from that person then we would
have moved on and then
sucked it up from somebody else and
moved on but now i think both of us can
be like wow that was really [ __ ] hard
but i actually feel whole i feel like i
don't need anything anymore i feel like
i learned
i learned my own pathology and healed my
own pathology to the point where
i'm good do you think that you could
still adopt this mentality of
sort of disconnecting from the
validation and not needing it
with one person totally do you think
that's a good idea
yeah like i think i'd be signed up for
that one well i think
i think feeling whole no matter what
yeah and then celebrating
you know celebrating whoever you're with
happiness you know genuinely without
needing anything from them so
if the person you know i'm dating
somebody now
and like you know we're just dating but
you know in the dating process there's
going to be other people that you see
and usually in dating protocol when you
just
starting off dating somebody you really
just don't talk about it
and and i was taught her like look i'm
happy for
you to tell me whoever you're seeing
like i'll i'll celebrate it with you was
it good do you have a good night she's
like
what do you mean this is crazy i don't
trust this i was like no for real
and then she like getting more used to
she's like yeah you know i had a
saw this guy and that was like how was
it she's like it was great i was like
that's awesome
she's like this is a trick i was like
i was like no it's not a trick like i'm
genuinely happy for you
you know like i'm just happy that you're
having a great time
and and like it's really interesting
because that's not the old me
old me would have been [ __ ] up would
have been really [ __ ] up on the
streets of new york yeah
i've been like what is she doing i
wonder if he's better than me i wonder
if she's going to love him more than i
wonder
oh my god and i'll be all freaked out
and it would ruin my day
and now you know knowing that i'm whole
and that i'm okay and that
if that person is actually better for
her you know that would be a
bummer but okay that's fine like
allow that truth to exist you know and
if that truth is what exists that's okay
because i'm
i'm whole it's not going to hurt me if
she makes that choice
i'll be bummed out but if that's the
right and best choice that's the right
and best choice don't you think it finds
its way anyway though
like if you aren't right for each other
it's gonna find its way anyway
oh without having to complicate things
with
pain which i i mean yeah
pain is a topic i want to talk about but
don't you think you can just go through
the transition yourself some people
together with one person
yeah sure some people some people can
become whole this is one way to become
whole
right this is not like the way for
everybody i'm not like saying
deep dive into becoming this is a deep
dive and for people who are particularly
screwed up you know in this nest who
really have a deep
need for validation from the opposite
sex which i did
like i don't think there was another way
i did i did all the ayahuasca i did all
the plant medicine i did all the other
things
i was trying i was trying all kinds of
stuff but nothing like brought me to my
knees to the point where i really had to
deal
with my need for particularly a female
to love me in an intimate way
for me to be able to love myself that
was the necessity for me to be able to
love myself
well this allowed me to cure that
pathology
and and and for whitney it allowed her
to cure that
for herself as well in her own way in
her own way for needing it wasn't so
much about the sex but it was about
the attention affection desire being
desired by
multiple people you know i think both of
us can say
yeah we made a ton of mistakes some
parts were amazing and some parts were
truly amazing like
true like i'm talking about the negative
parts there was amazing parts we had
amazing times together and so much love
shared not only with each other but with
other people as well but you know really
it's a path of growth
and what we do in the future you know
what we do in the future is
is undetermined but i think you know
really looking at this
maybe it's a long-term solution for some
people maybe it's just a path of growth
i certainly wouldn't do it the same way
that that we did it we learned a lot
we went way too far in some ways you
know and i think
we made a lot of mistakes yeah um but
the learning process that's the learning
process there's another point
of your three major mind themes which is
resistance
using resistance as a point of
assistance which you know kind of feels
like this where you're like
man this is really freaking hard and i
you know how do you use that as a pivot
point to
growing and i have my own sort of saying
for that sort of
mindset which is the only way to the
other side is through
like you have to get through it which
it's not going to be easy
yeah so all right let's go back to that
moment in new york whitney's with her
aggressive lover
i'm in i'm in new york i'm crawling
around in the ground not knowing
crying not knowing if i'm gonna vomit
not knowing what i'm gonna do and i
i ask the universe for help one
thing that's a benefit because i rarely
ask the universe for help and it's not
because i don't need help i just it's
not
something that i do so putting me to the
point where i asked
for help already one major benefit
sure of that moment right like like it's
just being like
yo i just can't i need help like source
universe god whatever your vocabulary
permits like i need help
and then i received some help and i
received a message that came through
at that moment and the message was the
sun does not judge itself by the shadows
that it casts
and i was like that is [ __ ] cryptic
and i was thinking about it for a minute
the sun does not judge itself by the
shadows that it casts
okay so if i'm the sun
i don't need to judge myself by the
effect that my light is having
you know so like the shadows that it
casts so my
how much she wants me or how much
i'm affecting her how much she's
thinking about me those are all the
shadows that my light is casting
you know it's like that's not how i need
to judge myself
that's not how i need to decide whether
i'm the sun like the sun doesn't look
at that person they sunburn it's like
[ __ ] yeah i'm the sun like i burned that
person
you know like oh yeah i'm the sun i
created that desert oh i'm the sun i
created that
beautiful beach environment like it's
just the sun
it is just being the sun and so that
lesson
came from an extreme circumstance so
that point of resistance became
assistance and that became something
that was this
focal point for me understanding the
true nature of who i was which is not
judging myself by
the effects that i'm having on the world
but judging myself
by purely who i am the essence of who i
am
which is you know you can call it light
or you can call it energy you call it
source you can call it love
you know and really love i think is the
best way to describe the essence of who
we are we're
love embodied and love and body doesn't
judge itself by how many people love
it back it just knows that it's love so
okay
deepest point of verse of resistance
comes
deepest metaphysical lesson polarity of
course right the greatest assistance
is also pointing to the you know the
dark side right because there's this
sort of dark side to us we have dark
dark the dark parts of us all of us do
what's that explain that well we're
you know we're cast into what could be
called polarity
polarity is the expression of love
divinity
light and then shadow resistance
darkness and
if that if those forces weren't equal
in power and then we wouldn't have free
will
because the board would be slanted and
everything would slide one way
so like the force of resistance and the
force of assistance the force of light
and the force of darkness
they have to be even in order for us to
really have choice
otherwise it's like loaded dice if you
got loaded dice you're gonna roll sevens
you know eventually all the time you're
gonna win every time playing craps if
the dice are loaded
right like it's not a game anymore it's
not a game it's not
it's it's a movie because everything's
everything's shifted and
us as an expression you know as within
so without we're like a little microcosm
of
the world at large so inside of us is
all the light
and all the dark and sometimes we try to
externalize this we have this idea of
like exercise the demons and
you know bring it like the demons are
within us and so is the divinity within
us the god and the devil are both
you know within within the human being
all of those aspects
it's just our choice as to which part of
us
we want to express you know because
we're all of it
yeah and really understanding that we're
all of it we're all the shadows we're
all the darkness we're all the [ __ ] up
thoughts
all the all of that's within us but we
can choose to express
on whatever spectrum of the polarity we
want to express
from the most extreme enlightened divine
side or from
the darkest power driven ego driven
denial of our divinity denial of
sameness
of all people and all beings we can
express that way too
and you can go through history and see
the people who've expressed
at the extremes and then most of us fall
somewhere in the middle
but really recognizing that we're all
we're all
the whole amalgamation of the whole my
you know macrocosm
makes me think of a question that i just
want to hear your perspective on because
with the
you know light and the shadow side of
the dark side
you know and the polarity um you know
good
good and evil what is your perspective
on heaven and hell
i think that's right here right now
i agree heaven and hell is like is it is
every day
that's where we are are we in heaven or
are we in hell i don't know it's up to
you
it's up to you you know like that's
that's really
that's really the truth and people
extrapolate oh this is a
actual place that we're going after we
die
no that's it's now like we can be in
hell or we can be in heaven and
you know and that's you know i have
great examples of that in my own life
like
i remember when i remember one of the
first most
clear examples of that is i was studying
abroad the university of queensland
and my girlfriend who i left at
university of richmond
started seeing a guy who was playing for
the pittsburgh steelers
and that was really hard for me i
[ __ ] hated that brisbane is amazing
like the sun is amazing the people are
lovely like the food was great
that my class schedule was great but i
was in hell
because all i was doing was obsessing
over her
with this guy who was playing for the
steelers to the point where
the only like thing i was focused on i
looked up his combine stats
i was like which one of these can i
compete with like that [ __ ] matters
but i did and i was like ooh is 225
bench press
number is suspect i think i can go it so
i put on pantera on my headphones
and i go in the weight room and i just
pump bench press until i
beat his score and then i thought that
would make me feel better it didn't
but you know like that was the hell that
i was living in i was living in a hell
of like
i'm in a comparison harrison is a thief
suffering
yeah exactly and all of this meanwhile
here i am in brisbane i could have been
in surfers paradise or nusa
grabbing a board having an acai bowl and
just loving life but where was i know
i was projecting myself to their bedroom
where this guy on the steelers was
hammering my bench pressing yeah yeah
damn it and that was
that's where i was and that was that was
my help you know and every single day
you know we have those choices now
certain circumstances are going to lend
themselves
and i get this whenever i mention this
people like well what about people in
these
really challenging environments and
challenging areas i get it some things
are going to be really hard it's going
to be hard to choose heaven
if you're in a concentration camp it's
going to be hard to choose heaven if
you're in a war-torn place
but then nonetheless like i've been to
the soweto slums in
in africa and i've been to some of the
poorest places on the earth and i see a
lot of happy people there too
you know and i see a lot of sad people
in the hamptons
as well you know what i mean so there's
people creating heavens and hells
in a variety of different places i mean
you go to these slums they're these
little shanties where
human feces is like rolling down the
hill right
and the kids have a soccer ball that
they've kicked the treads off of
all it is is the inner bladder with
those little weaving things and maybe
like one square
and they're playing with that ball like
it's the most exciting thing they've
ever seen
yeah you know and then you'll go see
kids
somewhere else in greenwich and they're
like so annoyed
because they're you know on their ipads
like their cell phone service is bad
yeah and they're they're just they're in
their own little hell you know and then
those are those are the kids but it
extrapolates to the adults as well so
you know really heaven and hell is is
something that we get the opportunity to
choose is this the kingdom of heaven or
is this
you know hell that we're in your point
of attention is everything
where you place that really dictates
your mood
dictates how you feel totally um
[Music]
well another your the third major
theme is surrender which is a huge one
for me because
completely surrendering surrendering to
a process or a timeline
detachment for me is like you know the
ultimate
difficult you know thing to wrap my head
around because
i'm a forward thinker not a back thinker
i don't regret anything i've ever done
but i'm sure as hell planning on
everything for the next 50 years
and um so detachment's tough so
you know where did that come from is
understanding that to be
a really important discipline
yeah i mean i i would love to say that
like i have these
great downloads and i just apply them
but really it comes from this
necessity right like i put myself in
uncomfortable positions
and then i see what works and what
doesn't work so
an uncomfortable position is doing an
ayahuasca ceremony an ayahuasca is a
plant medicine which causes a strong
physical purge and generally they call
it either the vine of souls or the vine
and death because it'll
have you confront some very dark you
know challenging issues
usually at some point you know it can be
anything really it's not like a formula
but usually you'll have to confront some
very scary things and some very
challenging things and my very first
ayahuasca experience
um which taught me a great lesson in
surrender which is one of the ways that
i learned about surrender
was it was showing me all of the ways
that i
you know i was i could die and i was
dying so like
i had snakes that in my vision state i
had snakes that were coming in they were
eating my organs from the inside out and
i could watch them eat my organs i was
like whoa
well that's a little bit scary but i'm
okay with that and i had spiders
crawling in my ears and bursting out of
my eyeballs and going to my brain i was
like that's scary too
and then the other one which was really
really i didn't like this one at all
i was sliding down a tree which was made
of spikes spikes on them
i was sliding down this tree made of
spikes and i was naked
so i was sliding down the street and all
the spikes were just eviscerating
all my genitals and my stomach and i was
like wow
that's terrible too but i'm still like i
was a bummer of a day yeah and i'm still
like
well you know i'm still kind of okay
with all this but then then ayahuasca
was like
you got cancer and i was like no no no
no no no
no i don't no i don't and i wrestled
with it and i fought i was like no i
don't i'm healthy i'm fine i started
checking my glands and i was like
no look i don't like it's like yeah you
do you do you're gonna die
you're gonna die slow painful death from
cancer
i was like no no no no and i started
resisting resisting resisting and i was
in so much suffering
you know because when the snakes were
coming the spiders were coming the vine
was coming i was just kind of like yeah
okay
you know it's not real and but when i
started to get in the resistance
of having this cancer diagnosis because
it's something you don't want it was
something i was really scared
really scared about because i'd seen my
uncle you know suffer from it i've known
that like
it was something that had a really
visceral response that my resistance to
it which is the opposite of surrender
right was causing this massive suffering
and i was purging and i was nauseous
and then finally finally at the end just
out of exasperation i go
okay okay if i do so be it
so be it and i just took a deep breath
and then ayahuasca felt like it came
from the ground underneath me
and embraced me and held me and it's
like you don't have cancer
you're fine you're healthy and i just
lay back on the ground i was like
it's like what we were talking about
about wanting something
so much that the polar opposite of that
is not wanting it
to not happen like you wanted to be
healthy so bad that the other side of it
as you so well explained is
you know you don't want to be you don't
want cancer so much you don't want to be
unhealthy because you want to be healthy
so bad
yeah so i had so much fear that i was in
so much resistance and as soon as i
surrendered
you know then then i was rewarded with
that and that you can find that in the
sweat lodge you can find that in
in life in business in the open
relationship you know i had a great
mentor in the
in you know as i was going through some
of the challenging parts in the open
relationship and he's like look this is
teaching you to surrender
surrender to these feelings that you're
feeling stop resisting them stop trying
to change them just
acknowledge and surrender it and you'll
know it's surrender when it doesn't feel
hard anymore
yeah and i was like oh it's surrender
when it doesn't feel hard anymore
i was like oh okay you know and
and that's that's the point where i
think people think of it like
giving up but it's not it's not giving
up it's actually
having faith that you're gonna be okay
that the universe has your back
and that everything is happening as it
should so it's really an act of faith
rather than an
act of defeat sure well it's like for me
and my
retirement i explain to many people
especially when i go
do speaking engagements that i had to
learn the difference between quitting
and letting go
like it's recognizing the signs
feeling things observing and not being
afraid of what's coming
that gives you the opportunity to let go
you know let go with grace as opposed to
you know quitting being forced to or
quitting being
a negative or stopping something as a
negative it's a positive i'm moving
forward
yeah you're making the choice you're
owning the choice yeah you know you're
empowering yourself
yeah and also bringing forward the faith
that
yeah the next thing that's coming is
gonna be rad two yeah you know and
that's
it's a it's an act of trust yeah you
know it's really a trust fall into the
universe at that point you know and
and i think there's ways that you can
practice that and be rewarded
and when you get used to that then you
know
then it becomes easier and it's not just
surrender to the negative stuff too it's
also surrendering to the positive stuff
like we had a chat about manifestation
right like
there's resistance to even getting
yourself to a positive state where
you're manifesting something positive
sometimes
but it's because you have resistance and
that resistance is maybe you don't think
you deserve it maybe you think it's got
to be harder maybe you think you got to
earn it maybe but if you surrender
to that moment and surrender to the joy
of that experience or
maybe it's you're afraid that you love
somebody so much you're afraid of losing
them so you're
not surrendering to how much you love
them right you can surrender to love
right like instead of being in
resistance like well i can't love that
much because if they leave me then i'm
going to be that hurt
it's protected like it's protecting
yourself it's resisting sure
whereas like the beauty comes in like i
[ __ ] surrender
and if if my heart gets broken
so be it i surrender to that too but i'm
gonna at least love
i'm gonna love you i'm gonna love life
i'm gonna love everything
without any resistance without the fear
without any
caution right and just really allow it
to be and just trust that i'll be okay
right oof it's hard life lesson
yeah this lifetime or the next or ten
hours
however long whatever it is however long
it takes um
speaking of um you had kind of you've
mentioned
ayahuasca and all kinds of different
things so you're
you're a you're an advocate of
psychedelics and plant medicine
for again you know am i an advocate of
open relationship
i don't know maybe if it's right for you
am i an advocate of plant medicine i
don't know maybe if it's right for you
it's it's a very personal choice it's uh
a lot of times these plant medicines are
trials by fire
and are you ready for are you ready for
a trial before why did you
why are you interested in it like what
made you interested in the first place
well because i'm not easily
i'm not easily you know taught i'm kind
of like
i needed something big to show me like i
came into my first
vision quest which was a psilocybin
vision quest in the mountains of mexico
i came into that and i was a staunch
atheist
i was like when you die you die you're
dead what does it matter like there's no
soul there's no anything like that like
like like sure i was so sure but
i had enough i had enough like curiosity
and also reverence for the native
american
culture that i was like okay vision
quest cool that sounds good i'm just
leaving high school you know
it sounds like something that a young
sounds like something that a young
warrior should do
you know so i decided that vision quest
was for me and i meet this
beautiful you know shaman out in the out
in new mexico and it's like we're going
to have psilocybin tea and i'm like oh
god
so i grabbed a rock from the iraq this
is your first time ever first time ever
okay with anything
grabbed a rock from the driveway and i
was like as long as i hold this rock
i'll know that i'm still here embodied
in this life
and i was like totally freaked out and
then what ended up happening was
you know at up to that point the most
beautiful experience of my life i felt
my body
evaporate and i felt what could only be
described as my consciousness my
awareness or my
soul exist independent of my body
and i was like oh [ __ ]
i got some things wrong you know like i
didn't think there was this thing that
i'm experiencing in its purest form i
didn't even think this existed
and that moment of complete reevaluation
of
everything that i had believed was what
led me down the path
and so it gave me faith in the process
gave me faith that these plants could be
used as teachers
for someone as stubborn and sure that he
was
right as i was and completely shift my
perspective
and that is you know to be fair i say
this is for everyone but the
the clinical research that's coming out
is showing pretty reliable data that
psilocybin in the right setting setting
at the right dose is reliably creating
some of these top life experiences for
human beings
so yes it isn't for everyone but it's
probably for more of us than not
not well when you just look at the um
you know you look at how many people die
from alcohol
or you know synthetic drugs
that are prescribed to them versus
natural plant medicines um there's not
even a comparison even a comparison it's
it's like it's zero right i mean i think
there's a statistic on marijuana
uh that's zero like nobody's died from
ingesting it like taking it in right
correct it's never been a death has it
been death for many like can you od on
psilocybin you could definitely take
more than you should
but it won't you know but it's not yeah
the the toxic effects
right such a level right that's not
really right it's not really what the
issue is it can be psychologically very
traumatic if you take too much but
the question is why was it ever illegal
in the first place when these are
natural products well i think people
regulate against the things that they're
scared of themselves
and when the ego is in control right the
ego is firmly in control it's scared of
the reevaluation it's scared of losing
its power seat
running the human organs right it it's
almost like an entity that
itself wants to survive by the belief of
the organism that it exists in
like the ego wants to be real like i
want to be a real boy
that's like [ __ ] like pinocchio or
whatever like i'm going to be a real
yeah yeah i'm going to be a real boy
that's what the ego says and it's like
oh this thing psilocybin
might show the embodied consciousness of
the being that i'm residing in that i'm
not really that real
i'm just kind of a temporary
apparition that is operating within this
organism so well what's the ego going to
do if the ego's running the ship
maybe it can convince other people to
outlaw this thing and villainize it and
make it
illegal i don't think it's this grand
conspiracy to keep people down and to
keep people stupid like people have
these
big conspiracy theories i think people
just regulate against the stuff that
they're afraid of
okay and so people who have strong egos
were afraid of these things that were
ego dissolving and so you know we
outlawed those but the consequences of
that
are that we don't have the tools to
really resolve the traumas and really
unwind some of these patterns and i
think that's the the
revolution that's coming with this next
wave of psychedelic medicine
what do you think what what what will
all be legal in
20 years
well i think you know i think you got to
draw a clear distinction between
a drug and a medicine you know like like
a drug
can be used and anything can be used for
actually both
you know to a certain degree you know so
like but um
but like alcohol is mostly used as
a drug it's an inebriate it's something
that actually lowers your level of
consciousness for the most part
and that's typically what it's used for
so but when you experience something
like
ayahuasca or you experience something
like the right dose of a psychedelic
it's not that you're not sober it's
actually like you're hyper sober it
creates a form of hyper sobriety you
feel more like yourself
than you felt ever before rather than i
don't even remember what happened last
night it's like i'm never gonna forget
this for the rest of my life
you know it's the opposite framework so
i think anything that engenders that
kind of
awareness and awakeness and the ability
to heal
you know i think all of those things are
going to become legal so what is that
that's peyote that's san pedro
also known as wachuma that's ayahuasca
that's dmt that's
iboga that's you know all of psilocybin
all of these different things marijuana
obviously is already on its way
but all of these things that can be used
as these tools mdma
they're all going to become legal mdma
and psilocybin are going to be legal
within the next three years they've
already gone through phase two because
things like suicide and they're already
transitioning yeah and then then the
decriminalizations happened in denver
the legalized nature initiative in
oakland
it's already on its way and it's already
happening but i think all of these
things will be there and then
we'll start taking a good look at these
other tools that we've used
which have been crutches and a lot of
these psychiatric medications
i mean there's some psychiatric
medications where suicidality and
homicidality
are side effects like chant like chantix
oh yeah the commercials that they have
to put on tv for you know three minute
commercial it's like me
may create drowsiness may so make you
suicidal
yeah whoops what yeah like hang on wait
what did you just say
is that the right tool you know and so i
think we'll take a real look and maybe
for some people it is but we'll be
a lot more we'll have a lot more
well-rounded approach
and opinion about all right what can we
do to actually cure people
because that's what we're seeing in the
psychedelic medicine paradigm is we're
seeing cures
we're not seeing you know people who are
hobbled and
able to just get by which is what a lot
of the
you know treatment options are now for
different psychiatric conditions it's
like take this pill forever and you'll
be kind of okay
but what we're seeing in with mdma
assisted psychotherapy
people who have severe post-traumatic
stress disorder
that is treatment resistant so none of
the other drugs are working treatment
resistant
are curing themselves two out of three
times like
two out of three people are curing
themselves from the
three sessions alone not and and not
only that not only are they curing
themselves
measured by the ptsd threshold markers
in a follow-up
of years later they continue to get
better
wow without ever having to do it again
right so it's like
it's changing the paradigm from okay
you're a broken person we just need to
apply this pill and you'll be okay
repeat just keep pushing repeat on this
pill exactly push your p
two give us your money exactly so maybe
all you need to do is
you can do this thing and you can be
cured and psilocybin is showing this
with one dose like
one dose smoking since most smoking
cessation one dose
you know depression alleviation one dose
anxiety alleviation
i mean the conspiracy thought of that
that i would go to is that and i
say this said this many times like
there's no money in wellness right
nobody no drug companies are making a
fortune off of people walking around
well some conspiracy to that
there has to be no doubt i mean that's
in these organisms you know i think
people have you know
when you're in an organism like a giant
pharmaceutical company
you know like that organism itself even
though it's not alive
it's it wants to live and it wants to
live and it wants to live
and by live it means it wants to be
profitable because these things die when
they're not profitable
like an organization dies when it's not
profitable all the people who are
feeding off
this mothership organism they have to
get new jobs and their security is
threatened and whatever so
it's really easy to just kind of turn a
blind eye
when you're actually the money that's
putting food on the table for your
children
your ability to take a vacation is all
dependent upon this organism
which is feeding you it's dependent upon
that survival
so then the organism itself starts to
have these profit motivations that
everybody's kind of like
just not really looking too deeply in
because
i love my kids and i love my family i
love being able to go to hawaii
and i love all these things like i don't
want to let this thing die because we're
not really helping people
so i think it's less of this overall
like we're going to [ __ ] the world up
kind of conspiracy it's more like
we're just kind of allowing this thing
to happen and make profits so that we
can get the money and then we can have
our kind of lives and
but i think that's all that is all
changing because look you look at
psilocybin
it grows in cow [ __ ] all over the world
who do you think was a for how long ago
and what do you think the first person
was thinking when they're like
were they just so hungry that they're
like god i've seen something like that
before that little shitty mushroom
it's j you know what i'm starving like
what happened where somebody goes i'm
just gonna
pick this mushroom out as [ __ ] you don't
see how it goes you know what's
interesting is like there's some
evidence that it's actually people
observing animals
ah that's created some of the aha
moments for this
so maybe they watched an animal like
because they've watched like
jaguar like one of the one of the
understandings of how ayahuasca was
formed was watching jaguars eat the bark
of the ayahuasca vine and then watching
them go into this kind of even though
it's not psychoactive with the dmt it
has a strong maoi
so they're like they're getting a little
bit you know different and people like
if someone observed that
and then there was you know and they
didn't die they didn't die and they
looked kind of like
high like the imperative to get high is
a universal all animals like to get high
dolphins get high on puffer fish
really elephant yeah oh dolphins will
pat puff puff pass
they'll get one of those puffer fish
toxins you know where it came from
but they'll like get a puffer fish and
they'll blow it up and they'll squeeze
it a little bit and release its toxin
and
just a little bit of that puffer fish
toxin will get the dolphins high okay
and they'll be like this in the water
like
looking around they love getting high
sending sonar out for the next
one yeah exactly elephants like getting
drunk
like all of these animals bears will
jump in and drink a bunch of liquor like
a lot of animals i wonder what the dogs
do my dogs do to get high
i don't know they'll eat your [ __ ]
weed brownies though in a second
but but yeah like animals have this
imperative to get high and i think
looking at the animals might have been
the way that it's like all right well
this animal this fox came in
and munched this mushroom i don't know
if foxes eat mushrooms i don't know how
that would happen but
and then look at it it's all like on
it's all looking around like
wow reevaluating the universe and then
maybe that caused the human to be like
what happens if i eat that mushroom you
know and that could be
that could be the way that some of these
things are discovered or maybe yeah
maybe someone's just
hungry or really curious or experimental
or
who knows but uh but i think there is
there is wisdom guiding
you know wisdom guiding us to these
tools because they're just too valuable
so what's um you know i feel like just
big ships are hard to turn
and and people are close-minded and you
know change is something that's so
difficult like
you know why do people struggle so much
with
change and you know changing of
changing a whole paradigm of something
or perspective
yeah i think it's you know that fear
of loss of control when we have this
fallacy of control
that we wanna we wanna hold on to we
wanna feel like we know what's gonna
happen we wanna feel like we're
anticipating all of the
possible outcomes and change puts
question marks in a lot of areas
if you're changing then your orientation
to everything changes if your
company is changing if the world's
changing if anything has changed the
presidency is changing whatever like you
can get scared about anything they're
going to affect me
how's that going to affect me you know
like we want to have everything solved
we want to have everything figured out
yeah even i'm like that you're like that
we try to
project in the future and figure out all
the things you know yeah
certainty sure about things so and
change
cuts the fundamental belief and
certainty
and i think so we avoid that if we're if
we're not
moving from fear to faith if we don't
have faith that the change is going to
yield a positive result which it always
[ __ ] does
i've i mean i just feel like for me
change is one of those things where
we're not actually afraid of something
changing because the idea would be
you're trying to change for the better
most of the time like something needs to
happen or been pushed to happen
it's the fixation and the attachment
to something that you've dreamt up in
your head
or a routine of life that you're
scared won't ever be again and the
thought of
humans with the word never again or over
forever
are really like powerful strong fear
factors like
i'll never see you again and i'll never
see that person at work again
and oh my gosh i'll never see my car
again it was my first one and
like we get us we have to let go of the
things that we've been so attached to
even though you're gonna get a better
car you're getting a lambo right or
you're getting a better job you're going
to get paid more you're going to be with
better people
you know you're going to upgrade your
relationship i know it's over but
just wait like i have i just feel like
we're afraid of
it's the death of something that is the
the the attachment which you know it has
to be the death of it
um that's the that's the part that we
can't handle
not the fact that something better is
coming or could be coming
and uh and that's you know it's a
double-edged it's kind of the
double-edged sword because we are in
this temporal existence
we have to let go of all of life like we
are going to die
yeah and we're going to have to give
everything up we don't get to take any
of this with us
yeah you know and that that idea is both
terrifying
and also what gives the specialness to
our lives like
you know there's a quote from the movie
troy which i really love
and it's the character brad pitt playing
achilles
and he says the gods envy us because
we're mortal
that makes everything all the more
precious right because if you have an
abundance of anything
you actually don't even care about it
anymore you get tolerant of it like it's
like oh yeah i got
all of the like when you're a kid and
you have candy
you know and like that you can't go to
the store yourself and get candy you're
like oh candy today
halloween [ __ ] great and then you get
a car and you have 20 dollars you buy
all the candy you want you're like i
don't [ __ ] care about candy
you know it doesn't matter anymore
because you have an unlimited supply of
it but it was the scarcity of it
that created that crazy like drive and
value for it and
i think so that's life itself right like
we can appreciate the fact that these
things aren't going to be here forever
and that can drive us deeper into the
present moment and we're not going to
have these bodies forever we're not
going to be this young forever we're not
going to have
these lovers forever we're not maybe we
will but maybe we won't but we're not
going to have these experiences forever
so let's really
really enjoy them yeah you know while we
can
and allow ourselves to mourn the past
and that's that's hard i mean as i
mentioned like i just
transitioned my relationship with
whitney there's some deep morning
like deep deep morning like [ __ ] i'm
going to miss her
mm-hmm again i'm going to miss her like
bad absence the death of something
and then i look back and then i look
back at all the times i just took that
for granted
all those you know sessions of making
love and kissing your was just like
yeah whatever you know no big deal and
then
then it's gone and you're like oh man
like you didn't i didn't always enjoy
that all the way
and those are lessons you got to learn
but then just allowing yourself to mourn
and to grieve that and to move on
and know that like okay learn that learn
that better the next time
so what's your um what's your what's
your mission
um moving forward and then
you know what's your and what's your
hope for the world
yeah i mean my mission is to help
people recognize that we are living in
heaven
if we choose to make it that way you
know and and that's the
that's the mission that i want to help
people realize and that we're all
co-creating this experience that's
really incredibly rad and beautiful and
that the earth is amazing and the people
are amazing
and it doesn't matter if you're on the
right or the left or what color or what
sexual orient
doesn't matter it's all we're all people
we're all animals we're all
we're all part of this earth part of
this ex this
grand game that couldn't possibly really
want the same thing
we want to be happy we do and so like
helping people realize that
so that so that we can enjoy this and
also preserve it
yeah i mean i think that's you know
that's my my greatest calling and so
that that again it always starts with
the individual
yeah so like i'm looking at that yeah i
want to do that for the world okay
aubry how about you be happier yourself
how about you enjoy the world
a little bit more yourself how about you
judge people a little bit less like i
can start right now with me and i'm
always
have to remind myself that you know it's
sometimes easier to project that i'm
going to help the world
and meanwhile i'm just grumbling to
myself worried about my own
yeah and that's the thing so so be the
one
yeah be the one who loves people you
know universally and equivalently
and then show other people that that's
possible yeah
and i think that's really um when it
boils down to what i'm realizing is the
most important thing
and uh [ __ ] i still got a lot of work to
do but we all
yeah don't we all well thank you so much
that was a great conversation
i feel like a lot of people are really
going to be helped by that yeah i hope
so yeah it's been great to be able to
hang it
and drop in on both these podcasts yeah
thanks
thanks everybody thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click
on the subscribe button
you